>> Laura: 2020 DEMOCRATS RUNNING
IN TO TROUBLE ON THE TRAIL.
IN SOME CASES WITH THEIR OWN
VOTERS.
NOW, THE CASE IN POINT, JUST
YESTERDAY SCHOOL CHOICE
ADVOCATES CRASHED ELIZABETH
WARREN'S CAMPAIGN IN ATLANTA
WHILE SHE SPOKE ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN.
>> NO ONE IS HERE TO QUIET YOU.
BUT WHEN THESE WOMEN HAVE BEEN
IGNORED THIS LONG, THIS IS THEIR
MOMENT AND WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
THE STORY.
>> Laura: AN INTERESTING LOOK
FOR WARREN AND AYANNA PRESLEY.
SHUTTING DOWN BLACK WOMEN THAT
WANT CHOICE.
I FIRST SAW THE SIGNS AND IS
THIS ABOUT A PORTION?
NO.
THIS IS ABOUT SCHOOL CHOICE.
THEY WANT TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
TOP SCHOOLS LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
JOINING ME NOW IS CHARLIE KIRK,
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT WAS
TURNING POINT U.S.A. AND LEO
TURLEY.
THAT DID NOT LOOK GOOD FOR
SENATOR WARREN.
>> LOOKED GREAT.
A TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
THOSE PROTESTERS -- LET'S BE
HONEST -- THEY WERE FUNDED BY
THE WALTON FAMILY WHO SHOULD BE
PAYING LIVING WAGES AND THEY
HAVE NOTHING IN COMMON WITH
CHOICE.
THAT WERE PAID PROTESTERS,
LAURA.
I CHALLENGE ANYBODY TO DISPUTE
THAT FACT.
THEY WERE FUNDED BY THE WALTON
FAMILY.
THE WALTON FAMILY HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY THE WAY, LAURA, I WENT TO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THEY DID PRETTY WELL.
I'M ON THE LAURA INGRAHAM SHOW.
>> Laura: THE CATO INSTITUTE'S
REPORT ON THIS, CHARLIE, SHOWS
MOST AFRICAN AMERICANS WANT
SCHOOL CHOICE AND THE THE
WALTONS HAVE DONE A LOT TO
ADVANCE QUALITY EDUCATION FOR
ALL CHILDREN INCLUDING
MINORITIES ACROSS THE BOARD.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A TELLING
MOMENT.
>> YEAH, LEO, I'M STUNNED BY
THAT COMMENT THAT YOU'RE INVALUE
DATING LEGITIMATE CONCERNS OF
WORKING BLACK WOMEN IN THE INNER
CITIES THAT THEY'RE SENDING
THEIR KIDS TO FAILING SKILLS --
>> GOOD PLAY, CHARLIE.
>> THERE'S A REASON WHY IN NEW
YORK CITY, THERE'S A LOTTERY,
LITERALLY A LOTTERY WHERE THEY
PICK AT TOTAL RANDOM INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES TO GET A CHANCE TO
GO TO BETTER SCHOOLS.
IN FLORIDA, FOR EXAMPLE,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS WON THE
ELECTION BY PROMISING AND
RUNNING ON SCHOOL CHOICE AND
BLACK WOMEN SUPPORTED THAT.
SENATOR --
>> Laura: LET HIM FINISH.
>> HE WAS -- SHE WAS LATER
CONFRONTED BY A PROTESTER AND
SHE SAID YOU SENT YOUR KIDS TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL.
SHE DENIED IT, WHICH IS A LIE.
SHE DID SEND HER KIDS TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
WHY CAN ELIZABETH WARREN SEND
HER KIDS TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS WHEN
THE BLACK WOMEN CAN'T.
>> I'LL SAY IT AGAIN, THAT GROUP
OF PROTESTERS WERE FUNDED --
>> Laura: YOU'RE REPEATING
YOURSELF.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THE
REPETITION.
FIRST OF ALL, THE LEFT HAS MADE
A COTTAGE INDUSTRY OUT OF PAYING
PROTESTERS.
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE THEY WERE PAID
TO ME.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
CANVASSES ALL OVER WASHINGTON
D.C.
PAYS PEOPLE MINIMUM WAGE TO HOLD
OUT CLIP BOARDS SAYING SIGN THIS
FOR ABORTION RIGHTS.
DON'T TELL ME ABOUT PAID
PROTESTERS.
THE LEFT HAS DONE THIS ON THE
BOARDER, ON THE ABORTION AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE.
I DON'T HEAR YOU COMPLAINING
ABOUT THAT.
>> I'M SAYING THIS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS --
>> Laura: AFRICAN AMERICANS WANT
SCHOOL CHOICE AND YOU DON'T.
WARREN WAS NOT ALONE YESTERDAY.
IMMIGRATION ACTIVISTS HECKLED
JOE BIDEN OVER DEPORTATIONS
DURING THE OBAMA YEARS.
WATCH.
>> YOU SHOULD VOTE FOR TRUMP.
YOU SHOULD VOTE FOR TRUMP.
>> YOU HAVE THE POWER AS A
CANDIDATE TO COMMIT TO STOP
DEPORTATIONS AND WE WANT TO HEAR
YOU SAY THAT.
>> I WILL NOT STOP ALL
DEPORTATIONS IF YOU HAVE A -- IF
YOU COMMIT THE CRIME, IT'S A
FELONY.
>> Laura: BUT IF YOU HAVE FOUR
OR FIVE DUIs YOU CAN STAY IN THE
COUNTRY.
THE TIMING IS INTERESTING.
OBAMA JUST WARNED THE DEMOCRATS
ABOUT THESE DEVICES.
THIS IS A TEST ON WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE OPEN BORDERS ENOUGH,
CHARLIE.
>> IT'S STUNNING HOW THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY SEEMS TO BE GOING
IN THE DIRECTION OF WANT TO
CATER TO FOREIGN NATIONALS.
JOE BIDEN SAYS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE EXTREME IN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY SAYING I DON'T WANT TO
STOP ALL DEPORTATIONS AND GETS
PROTESTERS.
POLITICAL ADVICE FOR JOE BIDEN.
NEVER RECOMMEND ANYONE TO VOTE
FOR YOUR OPPONENT.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
TRYING TO COMPLETELY DISMISS IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
IT'S AMAZING HOW THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS SAYING WE WANT OPEN
BORDERS AND NO LIMITATIONS.
>> CAN I GET IN HERE?
JOE BIDEN IS TRUMP'S WORST
NIGHTMARE.
ACCORDING TO EVERYONE, THE
DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINTS, THE
DEMOCRATS WANT OPEN BORDERS.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT.
JOE BIDEN IS CONTRARY TO THE
POSITION OF OPEN BORDERS.
THOSE CRAZIES THAT ARE THERE,
WHEN IT COMES TO THE GENERAL
ELECTION, THEY'LL VOTE FOR JOE
BIDEN OVER TRUMP BECAUSE TRUMP
HAS A PROBLEM WITH MINORITIES.
>> Laura: REALLY?
THAT'S WHY EVERYBODY HAS TO RUN
AROUND CALLING DONALD TRUMP A
RACIST, DONALD TRUMP IS A --
THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE.
OTHERWISE THEY HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC RECORD OR
ABOUT WHAT HE'S DONE FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
THEY DON'T WANT SUBSTANCE BUT
THEY WANT TO BRAND PEOPLE TO
SHUT DOWN CONVERSATION.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF IT, LEO.
PEOPLE WANT TO GET TO SOME
SOLUTIONS.
I THINK THEY'RE FAIRLY
REASONABLE.
MAYBE PEOPLE SHOULDN'T TWEET SO
MUCH, TRUMP AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
IN GENERAL, PEOPLE WANT THE
COUNTRY TO DO WELL.
I THINK THAT.
I THINK THE LEFT IS WAY OFF
POINT HERE.
I DO.
>> I HOPE TRUMP HEARD WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT NOT TWEETING AS MUCH.
I HAVE NEWS FOR YOU.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMY
BECAUSE TRUMP INJECTS HIMSELF IN
EVERY SOCIAL ISSUE.
>> Laura: THEN WHY ARE THE
DEMOCRATS SO PARANOID, CHARLIE?
EVERY WEEK IT'S ANOTHER PERSON
GETTING IN THE RACE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THIS IS FLAT-LINING IN
THE BATTLEGROUND STATES.
THEY'RE NOT MOVING THE NEEDLE.
PETE BUTTIGIEG WON'T BE
PRESIDENT.
SOUTH BEND, INDIANA MAYOR WON'T
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
MAYBE DOWN THE ROAD.
NOT THIS TIME.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IN A RECENT POLL SHOWS THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS UP AGAINST EVERY
MAJOR DEMOCRAT IN WISCONSIN AND
DOING WELL IN STATES LIKE